extreme issues
let's see what biden says about
elections let's see the difference i see
why we're wrong
it's no longer just about who gets to
vote or making it
easier for eligible voters to vote
it's about who gets to count the vote
yes i'm not even kidding you
that quote was attributed to
joseph stalin yes it was that was a
quote
our president i got a point
our president literally just quoted
joseph stalin on television
well why not he's also [ __ ] quoted
mao
i mean jesus christ i saw this clip and
i was like
how how how ravaged is your brain that
you thought saying that was
a good idea
oh well remember he just read whatever
they put on the teleprompter for him so
whoever wrote it
somebody wrote that and thought it was a
good idea
um who gets to count whether or not your
vote
counted at all it's about
it's no longer just about who gets to
vote that's pretty much the case
making it easier for eligible voters to
vote
it's about who gets to count the vote
who gets to count whether or not your
vote counted at
all it's about
what does that mean who counts the boat
what does that mean
it means that if when you get to control
the process you can be in power forever
so we can never we we can stop trump
forever
i mean and let me tell you
you were talking about earlier you know
why doesn't why doesn't tucker just go
out on his own
let me give you an example of what
jensaki said today
uh with these social media platforms uh
and
those engagements typically happen
through members of our senior staff but
also members of our covet 19
team uh given as dr murphy uh
conveyed this is a big issue of
misinformation specifically on the
pandemic
in terms of actions alex that we have
taken or we're working to take i should
say
from the federal government uh we've
increased uh disinformation research and
tracking uh within the surgeon general's
office
we're flagging problematic posts for
facebook
i'm sorry what happened to my private
company private company bro
the federal government is literally
[ __ ] now flagging things for social
media
platforms yeah but then the private
company removes its private company
no i get the workaround but my point is
is that so that there's an entire
federal government testing pride a bunch
of interns right
that are sitting there and have to go on
facebook all day do searches get into
these groups
and they're flagging the government is
now flagging stuff
for facebook and twitter to take down
and youtube look i see your point royce
but
you know um when you own a restaurant
let's say you got to keep the health
code level above a certain thing i mean
you know it's the same thing as that
right first off i wouldn't own a
restaurant it's a money pit it really is
terrible the margins on you have to sell
so much booze because the margins on
food is so bad
um yeah but you know that's that's just
it just
it's more regulations royce i mean just
because your private business doesn't
mean you have can't
follow the rules
office we're flagging problematic posts
for facebook
uh that spreads this information we're
working with doctors and medical
professionals to connect
uh what about the doctors that came out
and said mass don't probably work what
about those doctors are those are the
bad doctors
are those the white supremacist doctors
are you saying that the biden ministry
are you saying that
president biden is a flag it yes he is
oh my god he is they are out there
false flagging everybody two connected
medical experts with popular
with popular who are popular with their
audiences with with accurate information
and boost
trusted content you know what that was
boost
trusted content oh yeah you got to boost
the goods my private company is now
is now listening to what the government
says and they're boosting it you know
when i always like point out
like you know a lot of people think that
these guys are just evil
and they believe this stuff but they
don't believe this stuff they're full of
[ __ ]
you could hear that in her just now the
way she stuttered on that
and the way she's talking really fast
even she knows
what the this woman is aware that the
things she
are she is saying are horrendous
and completely counterintuitive to our
you know to our constitution
she knows what she's saying is evil so
she's trying to rush
through it and that's why she hit that
stammer she was like that's what popped
up the problem flag flagging
questions you got all these questions
you keep
the guy the guy the guy she's turning
into joe bluth
get trusted content out there we also
created the covid19 the covid community
corps to get factual information
into the hands of local messengers and
we're also investing
as you'll have seen in the presidents
the vice presidents and dr fauci's time
in meeting
with
jesus [ __ ] christ man
but you're the crazy people you're the
you're the evil people
remember that remember that no matter
what you do you're the bad guy
and if you're a black lives matter
antifa if you're one of these people
that's like
likes trying to [ __ ] burn down
courthouses every weekend and
get in a fistful i need you i want you
to understand this and mark my words
we're all headed to the same [ __ ]
camps
so if you think that like if you think
you useful idiots
are going to be part of the new
proletariat that's that's not how it
works
they're going to remove everybody who's
problematic they're just using you
to gain momentum to get rid of us and
then the minute they get rid of us
they're getting rid of you too like do
you think that the future regime
wants antifa and black lives matter
running around crying and wanting free
[ __ ]
do you think that's the like anyone who
thinks that
socialism is the end game for these
people you're
you are absolutely these are the same
people
that promised you no more student loan
debt hey royce how are those student
loan debt forgiveness program how's that
coming along
oh oh you're serious royce's reply has
led me to believe it's not going as
planned
um what happened to all that what
happened to universal basic income what
happened all the
you're not getting it you see they're
going to get rid of the right wingers
because the right wingers are the most
dangerous and problematic
to any sort of you know regime that
wants control
and they're going to let the guys who
want control and lick the boots
they're going to use you to help wipe us
out and then
when they're done with us they're coming
for you we're all going to the same
camps
and by the way right wingers are uh
predominantly in better shape
tougher and more masculine than you
people on the left are
so then you're going to come to the fema
camps
and we're going to bully the [ __ ] out of
you because that's gonna be our last
attempt
to ever have any kind of fun in our
lives is gonna be just
bullying you people at the [ __ ] fema
camps
like oh were you an antifa guy oh man
we're gonna beat the [ __ ] out of you
later it's gonna be hilarious